[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview
a first look at what is on the front
pages in the next half hour or so we'll
see what's making the headlines with
the consultant editor of the daily mail
andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire
they will be with us right through until
midnight for our extended news review
so let's check out the front pages then
return of holidays if you
are vaccinated that is the lead story
for the telegraph
which says britons who have had both
kovid jabs
may soon be allowed to visit countries
on the government's amber
travel list without having to quarantine
the metro leading with those expletive
filled messages between boris johnson
and dominic cummings about matt hancock
the headline
nuclear dom hopeless the mirror puts the
prime minister's description of his
health secretary front and center
that is also the splash for the guardian
but the times reports that matt hancock
is to be cleared of allegations that he
lied
to the prime minister despite the claims
from mr cummings
the star doesn't miss an opportunity to
poke fun over the whatsapp exchanges
the express isn't concerned telling the
former advisor we've got bigger fish to
fry
financial times meanwhile leading with
the biden putin summit
in geneva saying the u.s president
warned mr putin of devastating
repercussions
if russian opposition activist alexis
navalny were to die in prison
millions of office workers could be
permanently working from home
due to a change in the law that's the
lead for this
for the mail and the son has spoken to
coronation street actor kim marsh
who is urging the public not to delay
medical check-ups due to the pandemic
after her father was diagnosed with
prostate cancer
so andrew and kevin here with their
choices uh we'll come to the telegraph
and the mail
and those kobe developments um in a
moment but first of all
um cummings again daily star i have to
admit i did chuckle
we think we've got this right the paper
says hopeless bloke said hopeless bloke
is hopeless says hopeless bloke
we shouldn't laugh anyway kevin your
take
yeah that's probably what saves uh
hancock to some extent
uh johnson because it's dominic cummings
who
has a very low public rating because of
his eyesight test to barnard castle
which nobody believes he
might be largely telling the truth they
might be totally telling the truth now
but do people still believe i think
what's incontrovertible
are the messages from the prime minister
that he produced down in street wouldn't
engage and say they were false
if they were false they would have been
out of the traps immediately
and stated that so it's quite clear the
prime minister at the beginning of the
pandemic did
think matt hancock was hopeless
although he said it in a rather fruitier
language
than that and of course you can see why
with the mistakes over care homes and
mistakes over ppe and the mistakes over
testing but will hancock be saved does
this keep him in his job
or does michael gove get the shift in a
reshuffle we believe he wants and and he
goes off
to to health in a period when there
might be a lot more money put into the
nhs
in a post covered recovery program who
knows
but i thought the the most significant
actually part of
the cummins uh dia tribe
was one he said the prime minister
repeatedly
lies and gets other ministers to just
lie to parliament and the public
and two boris johnson fancies leaving a
couple of years
after the next election and make lots of
money and have fun that in the longer
term could be the most damning
uh allegation if all of a sudden voters
and uh mp's tory mps
think he's just there and his authority
will begin to wane if they think he
is gonna he's gonna leave and he's just
doing it for himself which
come on let's be honest he probably is
yeah daley mirror asking the question
andrew
15 months and 128 000 deaths
after the pm's dummy verdict from his
health secretary how come he's still in
the job
my question to you is is it possible to
retrofit arguments
uh into this chaos of a global pandemic
if you looked at america at the same
time
you had states trying to outbid each
other for ventilators because there was
no
federal purchasing i mean it wasn't just
this country in a
a world of pain over pandemic
preparedness
and all the ppe was was in of all places
the wretched china uh so we had to go on
cap in hand to china to buy our ppe uh
we
we back in as far as 2015 when jeremy
hunt was held secretary in teresa may i
know david cameron was prime minister
they were told this country was told
there had to be better
preparations for pandemics and we didn't
do it
all around the world some of the
greatest countries in the world were
caught hopping
all those countries at g7 the other day
they were all caught hopping
italy we saw people dying on
on trolleys and corridors in hospitals
we never got to that state quite
and the trouble with cummings is um
kevin's right you know
that the public have delivered their
verdict on uh dominic cummings because
very soon after his um outburst at that
what was it seven hours in a commit in a
government committee
a raft of polls were published which
showed the tories having an even bigger
lead
they see him as a bitter and twisted
liar uh he lied over at barnard castle
he lied again in my view when he went
before the select committee
when he refined his story about barnard
castle uh
some of what he may have said about the
health secretary may be true
he's clearly very bitter that hancock is
still there
um but i also think the criticisms are
right at the beginning of this pandemic
when it was really
panic stations in number 10 in the
department of health
probably the same in the in the elysee
palace germany
all major capital cities they were
trying to get to grips with this
and on one of the occasions when boris
apparently uh used that rather colorful
language to describe
the health secretary that was the day
he'd had his uh been confirmed that he'd
actually got her on a virus so he was a
man
under even more stress than normal i'm
not excusing him but i'm just saying i
think people will read into this
and think this was a very very difficult
time for any british prime minister even
tony blair has said
it was probably the most complex set of
problems to face any british prime
minister
since the war but the mistakes were
legion uh
to many people were they're not looking
looking on even at the time
and where does this end the guardian
suggesting that dominic cummings has
hinted that he intended to continue his
campaign
against johnson's chronic dysfunction so
whole idea that he did a thumbs up and
declared victory before walking out the
room
to avoid serious discussion on subjects
and was unproductive compared to dominic
rob
i mean the accessions go on don't they
yeah that was quite interesting on the
comment on dominic rob when he took over
as
his acting prime minister that he come
in says he could share a meeting without
just uh
telling free stories and and gags which
suggested a lack of seriousness by the
premise at the beginning of the pandemic
if you recall he he claimed he'd be in a
hospital shaking hands with covered
patients with no covered patients in
there
but he's shaking hands uh when that day
advice had been issued that you
shouldn't shake
hands so i think that that can hurt him
but dominic cummings
said to the health and sign select
committees
he would produce evidence to back up all
his assertions he hasn't yet
done that we haven't seen the promises
yet by
hancock he says that he actually made i
think he's got to produce yet
um i'm enjoying reading it all it gives
you an insight
into uh to what went on it also confirms
uh your belief because somebody like me
who thought
uh dominic cummings was uh i think was
david cameron called him a career
sociopath i think that's been born out
and you think why was he ever in the
heart of government the problem for
johnson
is if cummings isn't telling the truth
then johnson has to answer
why did he take a fantasist into number
10 and have him
as his chief advisor after letting him
run
the brexit campaign i think we know
where that's gone i'll disagree with
andrew but i think it's been utterly
disastrous and the country was lied to
back in 20 2016
but he's got to produce more evidence to
back up
what he is asserting but even then even
then
it's possible that the prime minister's
vaccine bubble might continue to be
pumped up and people as you as you and
andrew are both saying
all governments around the world were
struggling i think it was britain's uh
misfortune that we had a show pony not
thoroughbred in number 10 and we had a
prime minister who was a bit lazy he's a
bit slab dash he's part-time he's more
interested in having fun making money
sorting out his divorce
getting married uh instead of focusing
on the big job and getting it right yeah
just want to move on because there's
some there's so
i was just going to say though in the
guardian they quoted jeremy hunt the
former health secretary
who chairs one of those committees that
cummings gave evidence to
and he said cummings has produced
nothing in that seven and a half
thousand
word blog or rant might be a better word
to describe it
that proves matt hancock lied uh and
uh and he said and it also confirms yes
sure
there is an element of chaos in number
ten he said but there would be wouldn't
there with
um the pandemic gripping the whole world
okay yeah the the um the times also
going on that
uh matt cartoon just very very quickly
boris sent mr cummings a text
describing matt hancock as really
excellent unfortunately the pm's phone
autograph
autocorrected that too dot dot dot you
can't quite see it can you
just uh lose that strap momentarily
there we are finally read it for
yourself now can't you
so let's go to the daily telegraph um
the news of tonight
that uh the telegraph reporting that
officials are drawing up proposals
that could allow people who have had
both coveted vaccinations
to avoid having to quarantine on their
return from ambulance countries and by
my reckoning
andrew this would mean this is the first
thing the government is giving you
for actually getting your double dose
absolutely and at last it's it's a [ __ ]
of light
now this is only a very early stage but
they are now
matt hancock is apparently not against
it uh a lot of government ministers are
looking at how to make this work but it
would be
it would be fair play you vote if you if
you've got double vaccinations
you can go abroad to an ambulance
country such as france
or spain and instead of then coming back
and having to quarantine for 10 days
no quarantining at all now you'll
probably have to go through a rafter
test
but you'll have to pay for but i think
this will be cheered up and down the
land because
people are fed up to the back teeth of
lockdown i know most of it's been lifted
but we're still stuck with
quite a lot until at least july the 19th
there was a bit of a shambles over
people going on holiday to portugal it
was always a risk
because portugal then went from green to
amber so there was then a great surge of
people
trying to get back causing all sorts of
inconvenience and expense but
this will really cheer people up and it
would be at last a piece of good news
for the aviation industry
which is virtually on its on the floor
now because
they've had such a torrid torrid 15
months so
i don't know how long it's going to take
to get this sorted but they should get
on with it
well a government spokesperson has told
us tonight recognizing the strong
strategic rationale and success of the
vaccine program
we have commenced work to consider the
role of vaccinations
in shaping a different set of health and
testing measures for inbound travel
telegraph suggesting it's at an early
stage officials still working on whether
um it would be returning britain's or
all arrivals
where the children would be exempt
because they wouldn't have had the
opportunity to be vaccinated
by july the 19th kevin yeah
the the telegraph say it'll go before
the cabinet in about a fortnight and uh
i think there's a little clue this is a
spin operation by
by the government to take away attention
away from what commons are saying
all governments do it sometimes they do
it successfully sometimes they don't
because matt hancock the hill secretary
is now
open to the idea and he's been uh
opposed before
so maybe that's a source for where the
where the telegraph
got the story but when the astra
double jab it gives you 92 uh protection
and the astra uh sorry the uh pfizer
jab double jab gives you 96 protection i
can see the case for this and
michael go who's been looking at the
idea of code certificates covered
passports
has effectively ruled them out for use
in the uk
but tony blair amongst others has been
saying for
weeks if not months that they will
effectively be used around the world
because countries when they open up will
want to make sure that people going in
are jabbed
and we're not quite clear yet scientists
aren't quite clear
how you pass it on if you're jabbed but
certainly you're not going to pass it on
as if you are unjarred okay
um we'll do the daily mail which is the
shock plans to work
from home forever in the 11 so stay
tuned for that
plenty more still to come though we'll
take a look at what happened at that
summit in switzerland
between presidents biden and putin
[Music]
[Music]
you